If they wanted to teach you, they would.
But they won't, so I will.
This is definitely gonna piss a lot of people off,
but it is what it is.
Do you wanna know why the NHS is collapsing?
Why there are major staff shortages
and wait times for treatments?
It can be pinned down to one thing and one thing only.
Immigrants. Immigrant Sajara.
In order to fully
understand what I mean by that statement,
we first have to take a look at the whole NHS.
Because most of us just know it as free healthcare.
And we love Americans.
We really mock them because of their healthcare system.
But there are
two things that we always get wrong about our own.
Firstly, the NHS isn't free.
It makes no sense when people say that with their chest.
We pay for the NHS through our taxes
and National Insurance contributions.
It's free at the point of use.
That is completely different
to it just being free. Secondly,
our healthcare system in the UK wasn't always like that.
The NHS is only 75 years old.
Most of your parents and grandparents
are older than the NHSS.
It was established on July 5th, 1948.
And before then,
if you got sick or you needed medical attention,
you had to pay for that.
And if you didn't have the money,
you just had to hold that one,
charge it to the game.
Now, there were some charitable
voluntary hospitals,
but for most working people,
You have to pay.
Now the question you might ask is
what changed in 1948?
We were able to have a government controlled
healthcare system
that you didn't have to pay for at the point of use.
And the answer is
immigrants. 1948 saw the first arrivals of the HMT
Empire Wind Rush,
which saw Caribbeans enter into the UK by the thousands.
The reason being that most
if not all of the islands in the Caribbean
were colonised by the British,
therefore they were English speaking
and England needed labour to rebuild England
after World War 2.
Many of the men and women
that came over from the Caribbean
ended up finding roles in the NHS,
including my grandmother
who worked in the canteen,
the hospital that I was born at
in the UK for almost 20 years. Now.
The NHS will always talk about
the history of their diversity,
but believe me,
the men and women that came from the Caribbean
to work in the NHS
were not paid very well,
especially compared to their British counterparts.
But one thing that immigrants from all over the world
are able to do with incredible efficiency
is to make more with less.
And they most definitely found a way to make it work.
Until 1950, there were less than 20,000
non white people living in Britain
and pretty much none of them were born on British soil.
So you all the racism was Champions League level.
It was elite.
Imagine you Uproot your whole life,
travel halfway across the world on a boat
to help a nation that colonize yours
and took all your resources
only to be told to go home by the locals.
This wasn't your regular degular racism,
this was top shelf racism.
But it was the cheap labour of the Windrush generation
that carried the NHS for decades
and made it financially viable.
But the British people really weren't too happy
with these foreign people moving in next door
despite like
the benefit they had to the community.
Regardless though,
the immigration continued.
In the 50, 60s and 70s
the South Asian community decided that
the UK was the place to be.
And then they came
and they contributed their cheap labor
into the healthcare system that is the NHS.
I actually still make up 12.5% of all
staff in the NHS today.
And you wanna know what also happened
in the 1960s?
Civil and political unrest in Nigeria
along with the UK recruiting skilled workers
from the country
saw a load of Nigerians also migrate into the UK.
The numbers of not just Nigerians
but other African communities migrated into the UK
steadily all the way through the 80s
into the early 2.
What did many of those Africans do?
They too came to work in the NHS.
So basically
from the NHS's conception
is relied on cheap labor from immigrant work forces
to keep it going
for all of these decades.
As soon as each Group's population
was deemed too much for the UK.
New legislations and laws would be passed
to stop their immigration into the nation.
This was the Brexit
before Brexit.
The original Brexit,
if you will.
Now it's important to note
the children of those immigrants
that came to work in the NHS,
forced to study in school
and do well
so they didn't have to take the abuse
and low paid jobs within the NHS
like their parents did.
If they did re enter the NHS,
they were being hired as doctors and surgeons.
Now this paired with the fact
that there were less immigrants entering the UK,
it left a void of cheap immigrant labour.
The NHS needs to be able to continue working.
Fear not, because in 1992,
in came the treaty of mastered.
This made it possible for all people
living inside one of the EU nations
to be able to move to other EU nations
and work for as long as they wanted
and stay for as long as they wanted.
And naturally,
many set their sites in the UK.
Doctors and nurses from the EU
would provide
essential services and assistance to the NHS.
But in 2,016,
the British population voted to leave the EU
and all of that was put to an end.
You see, now
it puts us in this real novel situation
where we're in a bit of a catch 22
because the UK want the NHS
that's relied on immigrant labour.
Since its conception.
But they don't want the immigrants in the country.
Now we're in a situation
where the NHS's staff shortages
could lead to its collapse.